احتجاجات وتظاهرات شعارات مناهضه للنظام
الايراني ولا صوت يعلو على صوت الغضب في
الشوارع الايرانيه في اخر القضايا التي
شغلت الراي العام في ايران حالات التسمم
التي اجتاحت المدارس وجديد القضيه طالب
عشرون محاميا ايرانيا اربعه منظمات دوليه
بتشكيل لجنه مستقله ومشتركه لارسالها الى
ايران للتحقيق بشان القضايا الاربعه
التاليه ما اصل هذه التسممات المتسلسله
لماذا تورطت المدارس الايرانيه فيها لما
تم استهداف الطالبات بالتحديد وما
الاجراءات التي يجب اتخاذها من اجل
المساعده وقد تم ارسال هذه الرساله الى
المدير العام لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
والمدير العام لمنظمه الامم المتحده
للتربيه والعلوم والثقافه والمدير
التنفيذي لمنظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله
ورئيس اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر هذا
واتهم احد الطلاب في جامعه الاهواز علي
سعيد جلي لي ممثل المرشد الايراني في
المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي الايراني
والنظام اتهمهم بالعجز عن حمايه الاطفال
في المدارس من السموم التي تستهدفهم